[Applause]
well welcome back to our special austin
series being filmed here at artemis
capital
right now we're going to be joined by
ted oakley a man i greatly admire
he's a longtime reader of my research
but that's not why i admire him uh he's
managing partner and founder of oxbow
capital here in
austin thank you for thank you for
taking the time today we're switching
roles a bit
thanks danielle because i'm usually
interviewing you
that's true but down the middle has a
kind of a mission we were talking before
we started filming of uh
of trying to convey to
younger workers you know just entering
the workforce
what people's stories can be and where
they can come from
and become accomplished successful
people who i would love to have on down
the middle so
you have a story in fact you call it
your story
i do i i do have a story i mean
it's not i don't think it's uh
i think there's a lot of people really
that have a story you know and so i
always i always love reading their
stories about how
your story yeah and so
i always loved reading about them and
what they have to say you know about
their life and how they overcame things
yep helps me
so how did how what was your beginning
where were you born
well i was born
in a little place called decoy georgia
forum lack of a better
place to give you from a geographic it's
about 30 30 miles from where deliverance
was filmed but
uh i don't want to say that
disparagingly by the way but
kind of telling you way up in the
mountains and i had a um
we were very we were poor we we
we just
we just didn't there was no money and so
we ended up uh we had we really had
you know outside water we didn't have
indoor we had outsourced plumbing i mean
it was
it was that kind of thing you know so
you didn't have any money so you had to
you know
i started working was six years old
but that's
yeah that's that's what you do
it is what you do i started working when
i was 12. yeah so i mean we do what we
do so how
take us
how did you clearly were in austin texas
now
you've been to dallas you've been to new
york you've been
in the army what was your journey out of
the mountains
how did that well my father was a
minister and he wanted to
decide he wanted to do somewhat of a
missionary approach to a lot of the
sugar beet workers in northern colorado
and greely and up in that area
and so
we went there and it was a you know we
lived we basically lived in the ghetto
but uh it was a good i mean it's an
experience for sure and i
i worked there too and we ended up uh he
always he was a texan so he always
wanted to come back to texas so
he worked around different churches and
ended up in east texas
and uh and that's where
i
left home when i was as soon as i got
out of high school i left home and not
not
not i don't say that's not a negative uh
on
any religion or anything like that it's
just it wasn't for me and so i went on
to um leave and of course i
you know i went and i was in the arm a
couple years
and then i ended up you know
i worked 40 hours a week to go to
college so
but you know what a lot of people do
that and that's why i'm saying it's it's
not so unusual but
i it might well it's more unusual today
than it
was back i mean i think financial aid
has changed how students behave and
changed how students approach
paying for college 100
i
nobody knows this but i would go down to
a banker
and borrow the money for
books and tuition and then i'd pay it
back
over the semester because i was working
right i do the same thing the next
semester
so
that's kind of like
a layaway plan for your for your
undergrad yeah but it but but it worked
and you know i um
i would have loved to have
study
you know more and do anything but when
you're
when you have to make it you have to
make it you can't do all the other
things and so
that's how that all happened and uh
really i've been very fortunate on the
way people have helped me that's why
um
i ended up on wall street in in
1976 and
i wasn't an ivy leaguer 1976 yeah i was
an ivy leaguer i was
sort of um
you know you know how it is i mean i do
know how it is to be on wall street
without being an ivy leaguer it's not a
lot of fun yeah and so
especially if you've got a little bit of
an accent yeah and if you're in if you
when you go into the room with people
you know if
if everybody in there is you know
harvard and columbia yale and every and
everything else and
stanford then you're like
but i know as much as you know if you'll
just give me a chance
exactly
so i've
uh but i've also been fortunate that so
many people helped me along the way
that's important do you have any
particular mentors who who kind of
guided your early career
you know i had a fellow and when i was
in high school i worked all the time too
and i had a fellow there
that helped me
get my sights straight his wife was a
teacher and he said hey
you can do this okay you can go on to
school and you do what you want to do
he was fantastic and he really helped me
i didn't see him after i left i saw him
one or two times but
then i had another gentleman who was the
greatest guy in the world he was really
more like a dad to me and he had double
degrees from oklahoma and texas law
degree it was everything
and uh interesting enough he was just an
investor
at home did all his own investing
and uh
worth a lot of money there were day
trading was a thing never had a credit
card
got a lot never had any debt god drove
the same car but yet i had one of those
um
with a cougar oh my gosh oh cougar had
an old cougar they had like 180 000
miles on
but he he taught me a lot about
just the basic you know debt
what you want to do i mean these are all
i mean that i mean the whole
you know financial literacy in this
country is
vacant it's gone totally it's it's they
they don't teach
people don't know the idea of having a
budget we don't have checkbooks anymore
you know you just have a debit card and
yeah
it it's it's interesting how how times
have changed but um
but 1976 so
jimmy carter's in office inflation's
flying
high right and paul volcker comes in to
the federal reserve right so what was
that like to be witness to
the rise of such an important and
um and disciplined
fed fed chair
well you have to remember that between
and really august of 82
we had a period where the market would
just trade between a thousand and 750.
so for a young guy on wall street i
thought that's what it did
stayed in the range you buy it at 750 or
800 and you got to get out of some of it
at a thousand or a thousand fifty
so then comes along uh boker and he's
really pressing it and of course
if you bought any bonds during that
period
by the time you got to settlement date
which was then a week
they were already down in price yep and
so you you you get into that kind of
thing and that's how you get sort of
raised
and then along comes henry copp
in august of 82
of course the great solomon brothers
call and and he anyway
so the market takes off and by 83 84 up
there and so people like me been around
already a few years are like did we go
over a thousand
and stay there yeah did we hold that
level we did
the price earnings ratio was a single
digit i mean you were witness to
well actually you were witness to the
last time the pe on the s p was a single
digit that's right and i'm my hat's off
to a fellow that works for me today
who was head of research for three or
four big firms on wall street and he's
87 years old and he called that for me
and said hey by the way
things are changing
so i see people help me all along the
way
he's still with our firm today because i
hired him out of when he retired
that's fabulous and he's still cranking
along he is and you know he's in great
health he's in houston and he's uh he's
just one of my good friends too
well that's that's
i mean i'll i'll tell you a funny story
i'll digress for a minute there was a
gentleman by the name of stan nobby at
dlj when i first started
and he said you don't exit
a well you don't exit
a bear market on the s p 500 until you
hit a single digit price to earnings
ratio
interesting and i'm still waiting you're
waiting i'm still waiting i'm so well
and see you know whatever era you grow
up in you have to
be able to adjust and really think
differently all the way it's it's i
remember the gas lines in the 1970s i
mean i was in the backseat of a car but
i remember i remember
it was pretty hot in san antonio with
the windows rolled down in the
summertime in those lines i mean these
dudes are just the memories that you
have growing but
but people i don't think have
i don't think investors
i don't think anybody has any concept of
of of a market that goes anywhere but up
it's interesting san antonio because
you'll remember this i in addition to
working on during the week i was still
in high school on the weekends i would
leave admit at 11 o'clock at night and
drive with a whole truck full of roses
san antonio texas tyler texas roses and
we would sell them on the corner
and they would we'd make a lot of money
and then we come we get back we get back
real like we drive then we pick them up
and then drive all night get back
uh to east texas like uh you know four
three or four o'clock in the morning but
man would make a lot of money because
they bought those roses san antonio san
antonio loves roses yeah san antonio
rose
um i haven't been back san antonio in so
long i hear great things
if i had the chance i i come here so
how did you what happened after new york
well first of all first of all were you
actually on wall street yeah on october
the 19th 1987.
no i was working in a firm but i don't
by that time i'd come back i came back
to dallas by the way and then and
actually
um
i i had
at that point in time
there was firm there was we two things
that happened we we had a pri i left
merrill lynch because we had a great
private company called rotan mosley
and um
we sold that company in 1983 to payne
weber
and uh yeah so one name from the past
and so um
over the course of uh my two partners
now and another company started
and uh we were it was hbo was that
coming and we
and you know i
i knew things were expensive then i mean
i had a fact we did a study in august of
and i had everybody go back and say well
if if you've made
23 24
by the middle of the year okay
what are the odds of you getting a lot
more than that by the end of the year
and it was like
two out of 50 or 2 out of 40 or
something it was a number where i looked
at and said you know fellas we have to
we need to raise some cash
so we were and august the 12th of course
greenspan that was greenspan's first day
on the job exactly and he
and um
and so
we had about 40 liquid just for that
reason we thought well you know
we're not brain childs or something
literally just
way worked out and we thought things
were expensive though too at the time
not compared to what they are today but
they were
and then greenspan comes in and he
decides as i mentioned to you earlier
he's going to be another paul volcker
which he's not
the opposite yeah and he raises the
rates
and so he gets the bond
you know i mean short bonds five seven
years like up to ten percent
and so all the money managers say hey
uh by the way i'll take that and you can
take this and so they sell their stuff
between friday and monday we're down 35
and alan greenspan on
black monday was in dallas texas was he
really he was he never he was there for
a big economic symposium where he was
just to be the keynote at the on october
the 20th but he never made it to the
podium all right he flew right back to
washington dc and that was kind of when
the fed put was born but uh
but
that era
that greenspan era you you saw that the
changing of the guard
at the federal reserve you saw
the world go from rational to
irrational right god i just said
irrational and he said irrational
exuberance in 1996. that was his deal
did you was it a subtle change in the
beginning
well my problem with greenspan and
really everybody else since him is that
i never believed them they would say
one thing and then they would do
something else and every time
every time something got the least
you know and i knew what was happening
we had such
pardon my word but we had such a lousy
congress really from that point on and
all the way till now
that people they sure yeah same people
the same people they shirked all their
physical responsibility what you should
get in government is congress
does a physical policy that helps the
fed so they don't have to get in there
and do everything right and it was
during the carter administration
when you were in new york that they gave
the fed the dual mandate the second
employment exactly so they they did the
wrong thing in other words
they ended up in a situation where all
of a sudden
you're in a situation where congress
like you know what
you take care of that yeah you do it
well
that's a bad thing when the only thing
you have to do it with is money
you can't do i've always said in all
these last 20 years i've said you know
you want to give somebody some incentive
tell somebody tell me as a business
person okay you hire somebody but it's
got to be 75 000 a year or higher or 80
or whatever the number is and i will
give you a tax credit for that by the
way or if you if you do try to incent
the things so you can take the average
person out here and bring them up of
course you know well all of ours
they keep them down
absolutely and we're going in we
continue to kind of go in the right well
maybe some moderation is being
introduced but answer your question i
saw that and you saw it between the fed
and the congress and it just keep kept
on going and now it's
well now we have
the fed congress and wall street
we're not going to go there quite yet
instead let's go to tokyo
oh
in 1989 yeah we we lost business in 89
we you know i had we talked to people
i remember i would um you know i wasn't
that old then but i but i knew that they
were expensive because everything there
was 80 or 100 times
oh yeah earnings and and some much more
than that
but people don't realize you know
the nasdaq bubble popped you know the s
p 500 pe was like 44.
in 1989 in japan it was 99 exactly i'm
like 99 i mean so people are highly like
well bubbles can keep inflating them
like apparently and so we would get
i wouldn't say we get run out of
people's office but we would get
we got fired some yeah because they said
hey you don't own japan so
it's a little like we won't get into
this but it's a little like crypto and
nfts now
i mean the same the same thing you know
and so they would be like well you you
know you if you don't own japan then we
don't have a place for you wow okay
well that worked out okay because here
we're sitting today and
you never made any money right no no i
mean that's you know we keep counting
the lost decades it's kind of like
university of texas football
it's getting better how many lost
decades it's getting better it's getting
better we have a good coach keep the
faith right
i'm trying every time i look to my left
i see memorial stadium and it upsets me
after this last season a little bit
better it'll get better i'm going to
take your word for that um
fast forward 10 years
you got more flack in 1999 oh yeah uh we
there was a thing going there's a there
was a term going around in between about
1997 and in 2000 we do a lot of work all
over the country so
we especially do a lot in california
and of course that was the silicon
valley push and so we these people would
say hey ted
we have a new paradigm i've heard that
word i don't know
i can't tell you it's different this
time yeah it's a new paradigm and i
so i would have these people that would
have 50 100 million dollars in stock
options non-qualified they would sell it
and i would say to them hey you might
want to cash some you they they wouldn't
they would cash them in but they
wouldn't sell it and i'd say well you
might want to sell some of that because
the irs will be here next year okay
and they're like no new paradigm yeah
and so by the time we got into the end
of 2000
and a lot of those had just
crashed i had
numbers of those people that could have
walked away with 50 million net worth
zero and they owe directly oh
so
i never went back to them and said how's
that new paradigm working out for you
really of course i wanted to but
that's what happens in those kinds of
periods when greed takes over like it is
right now
you
you can't sober people up they're like
the greed is just too much of a push
and that's what happened then we had
really we had a really good investing
period between
and 03.
and not because we're the greatest
investors in the world but because we
had enough liquidity you had dry powder
and we had we had you know we had some
fixed income
and uh
we could see that it was so crazy
that
i remember a bet with a mutual fund
manager that said i said hey that when
the nasdaq was a tie i said well it's
gonna
you know it's gonna break down at least
25 percent i'll bet you dinner on that
yeah he said okay well when it broke 25
i said tell you what
i'll bet you another dinner that goes
down another 20 points and he's like man
i've got this one
oh boy so i
it's uh 80 later yeah there you go
you got it
um
speaking of high multiples and speaking
of dry powder which i just mentioned
you know if you look out the window you
see lots of cranes
and austin's not unique
and there's still building going on in
places like new york city
today
um
talk about some of the parallels that
you are starting to sense in the
commercial real estate arena and how
commercial real estate
is related unlike prior cycles to
residential like it's never been before
well it's a good point and by the way
you write some i'm trying to plug you
here because you write so many great
things about that and the piece you did
yesterday was off the charts by the way
but here but you're right on the money
and what happens is
people have an idea over the years they
have this idea that you can't lose money
in real estate of course i always wanted
a hard asset i always want to say
yeah do you know this do you know this
particular symbol rtrtc
do you
remember and they won't know what that
means you know but i'm saying if you if
you know that then you'll know what can
happen with real estate and so
what happens now is this is what i see
now is that
everybody has done so well with it and
the money has pushed it so far
that
nobody is listening to anybody they go
okay i'm gonna
build more houses
we're gonna put more big buildings up
out here we don't yeah it's 25 full
but
you know it'll be okay we you know we
get offered things all the time the real
estate side i had one three or four
weeks ago and said hey
we've got this great office building now
when we have one tenants at 75 percent
of the lease
but they're moving yeah i said we
already bought it yeah i said what are
you going to do when they i mean when
they got a 75 what if they don't what if
you don't leave see that's kind of thing
that's going on right now so what
happens is you end up with a situation
where people
have had it good for so long
and every time something happens of
course here comes you're fed you know
they i
i one of my my one of the best analysts
i have and runs he's our chief
investment officer said this the other
day that
the stock market has become the savings
account for the federal reserve for
individuals
and that's rollover and to a degree in
real estate as well so you have all
these things
and it's been so easy
again i talk about this but it's been so
easy then why would i want to worry
about doing
valuation looks and trying to do my work
on something when i can buy
companies at 10 times revenue spax nfts
cryptos
and you know they all go up anyway
why would i do the other yeah that's
where we are today that is where we are
today but we're not going to go there
yet yeah we're not going to go there
quite yet um
let's go instead to uh
to the last time we had real disruption
in the corporate bond market right so
this is
0.50607 07 i think junk bond yields
junk pawn spreads hit their all-time low
they're lower today if you adjust for
yield junk bonds are even i mean about
they're yielding negative for god's sake
um
but what was
what was that bernanke era
like prior to qe
well i i always felt like these fed
presidents wanted to sort of be the new
messiah they wanted to be the one that
says you know i got this okay
and bernanke's
started out that way too you know he'd
written that paper on helicopter money
and all that sort of thing oh yeah so
what happened is you you could sort of
you could sort of see it
coming and you know they they completely
brushed off
um you know the the subprime thing you
know they were worn it's contained yeah
oh yeah we've got janet yellen out on in
the san francisco fed with countrywide
in her backyard exactly just clueless
and so
that would be madame treasury secretary
exactly
and so
you
that's how it started in there and you
knew you you could tell
what was going to happen and so they
were like okay i've got this and it all
was born out
i think this whole thing was born out
of his research that he had done on a
depression i think where we are today
came from that okay to that you know
what
we know what happened then they didn't
really have enough money so you need to
flood it
that was his thesis we can fix it right
right and so what happened is that's
what they did that's what he started
doing and then everybody else followed
suit
but it was
it was always interesting that
i've never had
any fed prison
own it
you can go back and say hey you made
this era or that one nobody ever owns
there is no accountability
by the way in the money management
business you have to own it
of course you do because somebody's
going to say
well what what happened on that one
that's right
so you get into that sort of thing with
people yeah
well i i think
i think that we might have a that we
might have had the notion in fact it was
here in austin texas when i ran into
richard fisher
and
well i was here for a ut game so it must
have been the fall of 2015 after you
weren't working for him you were just
ranting just met him we both no we we
both just retired oh
another later on
i just finished working for him for nine
years okay plenty of time working for
him
uh but we ran into each other in the
lobby of the driscoll hotel
and this is the fall of 2015 so he's
been retired a few months from the fed
i've been retired a few months from the
fed
and he said well sit down for a second i
said okay he said i want you to pay
attention to one person and only one
person there's only one person who's
pushing back against bill dudley and the
others who want to keep reinvesting and
maintain the size of the balance sheet
he's he's really got fiscal discipline
and he's just like me he's not a phd in
economics so pay attention to this guy
named jay powell good friend of mine he
used to read he used to read your briefs
danielle he knows your work i'm like
okay but it's kind of hard to pay
attention to somebody who doesn't say
anything
because he was just a very quiet
federal reserve governor when he was a
governor and he just quietly continued
to push back
against all this craziness
until he got to office yeah
you ever seen the movies where they
reprogrammed
the brain you know and then the person
jumps up and they can
go different yeah well right but
but no but this goes back to your point
about bernanke and the great depression
right and how they addressed the
aftermath of the subprime
crisis yeah right
and now we see it in corporate credit
totally
right you're right so
i mean in a way
powell was stuck
he
he was between a rock and a hard place
the way it came came about right
and we became too dependent on the stock
market you know it's flipped now
used to be you know
the economy would be great and then the
stock market and now you know you know
what it you write about it yeah
it's that way it's flipped
so
where do we go from here
well i we think that uh we're in a
period a lot like the 40s where you know
i've got this graph two graphs i put
together that
show that the the 90-day treasury bill
and stayed at basically
one to one and a quarter from 1940 to
and then you saw the
the price indexes consumer price index i
mean they just kept right on going and
they never slowed down
it's interesting to us because i've
looked at a lot of different periods and
we didn't think we were going to go back
like the period i was in where you had
you know 18 prime right right right that
kind of thing
we felt like it'd be more like that
which then they didn't have to own it
they could say you know what we're just
going to keep the rates low
if and we're still going to inflate some
number maybe it's like uh your friend
and my friend jim bianco says it maybe
just be five or four and a half five six
it doesn't make any difference if you're
only getting one
you're going backwards and so what
happened is
uh i think i think that's where we are
on that part of it and we all i also
think what that's going to do
is probably put you in a position where
the stock market is going to be like
like it was
most people want to realize this between
january 1 of 2000 it took you until
2012 to break even wow
now nobody going to tell you that
20 years because all they're thinking
about now is look at the last 10 years
and they show you know when you go in
and look at numbers
this is my three year this is my five
year this is my 10 year of course and
i'm like wait a minute
i can show you
1966-83
and i can show you general motors and
sears and all those big stocks oh yeah
no splits same price
yeah and so
and and then when you get into that with
people like
cisco systems you know dream stock of
the 90s late 90s 82 high
in
january of march i mean of 2000 oh 82 to
8.
and it's still today it's not bad see
it's like japan
so i think you're going to get into that
where you go through a period and here's
the problem with most people in the
business
when you go through a market that just
does waves
if you don't know something about
putting money to work lower
and taking money off when things are
more expensive
you're going to get buried and the
reason you are and and this is why i
think it'll be this way
the entire industry today
is built around 60 40
or
ets
index funds and it's basically what i
call a plug and play market we're going
to plug you in
and we have all these people that
like i mentioned before that are wealth
advisors that have no wealth
so they just plug you in and expect you
know 10 years later you'll be okay don't
worry about it and interesting we
we do and they do tend to oh yeah
they're all they're kind of cookie
cutter it's a generic
i could bring 20 in and they all look
alike and they'll all say the same
things and giving an example
90 of our business across 30 states
comes from people that sell a company
and they get a lot of money oh yeah and
it's interesting
and so they'll say they'll say
exactly or death or divorce you've got
it yeah uh and so
they'll say something like uh well i'm
talk everybody i've seen here said you
know just do the 60 40.
and you know over 10 years let me show
you the last 10 years five years they
get that thing
and i wrote a piece about a year ago
that was it was entitled there is no
40. uh-huh because there isn't yep so
i'm saying wait a minute
so i can show you all these bonds out
here and like this year every bond
fund's down yeah
now our conservative accounts
which have some bonds in there their
legacy from a long way back
but they're up for the year not a ton
but they're not down right right and so
what happens is
people i think that's what we'll go
through and i think it'll be a long
drawn-out affair and you'll end up with
people in a position where they say
you know what
i'm paying you one percent a year or
whatever number that you want to pull
out of the air three quarters
and
i haven't made any money in the last six
or seven years i'm okay yep pancake
you've made more money than i have
that's what happens in these periods
because that's what happened between
2012.
we we got a lot of business but if
you're talking about
markets stuck in a range like that
passive doesn't work
doesn't work
and you have to have liquidity if you
look at the two biggest years we ever
had really three
it was 87
and 09.
not because we're geniuses by the way
you know danielle really is not we're
not bringing us it's just because you
had to have the sense
to have an insurance policy at least
have some liquidity
you know i wrote a book uh written a
number of books one of the books i wrote
it's called the psychology of staying
rich and the point of of it was and i
interviewed a number of billionaires
and everyone to a number would say i'd
find out that they had on average about
35 liquid all the time
all the time
and uh if you ask them the question why
is that and they said because
i want to be around because things are
going to get bad and cheap and then
that's when i just clean up
they're all the same
then you go out here to somebody that
only has five million
no cash okay okay and i always say to
them
you wanna learn something from
you wanna learn some warren buffett
just two weeks ago just announced the
most cash you've ever had in the books
okay
that's saying something yeah wake up you
know there's a there's a reason really
good people know how to have a balance
and
and i think that's where we're headed i
think people i have
i see people talk to me we don't do
business with them they're 80 years old
how much you have in the market oh i'm
about 90 oh god i'm like well
i know but you're 80. so you gotta
you know that's where we are today
though and that's what i think the way i
think it'll play out will be that way
what are jay powell's options
he doesn't have many i think what
happens is is that they're going to job
on it like you know all about that and
you know and i was it was like the 15
billion thing i'm thinking okay
everybody thought you're gonna do 20 or
25 billion cut back
you do 15 just to say well you know
we're done you know if they're doing
that thing
and one of these days i think they'll
get in a position to where you know i i
don't one of the things i am i know
about this business and that's why i'm
extremely humble
is because
i've been humble
many times
okay
if you get arrogant in this business you
will get murdered and so i'm always
looking around and thinking okay what up
what am i what am i missing here because
a lot of people think well he's going to
have to raise rates we're going to
inflate
we might not it might just be dullsville
and they can't get anything going either
way but has to do with
if they're going to really take away
that
the buys you know not for me it's not so
much the raising of the rates
but i don't even know if i'd have the
guts to quit buying bonds
well that's that's exactly the point i
mean i i i keep thinking that powell's
waiting for something bad to happen so
he has an excuse to pull the plug on
tapering yeah and that's kind of the
sense you have but and that's arrogance
oh total and i i there's one thing and i
honestly i i've made more mistakes
than probably anybody in the business
but i always learn from them
i think well the next time you know i'll
know not to do that
they don't seem to learn very much but
my my thing is if you're still buying
a hundred and five billion a month
that's a lot of money
and p i don't think
aig bailout was 85 billion exactly at
the time we were like
wow that's a huge sum of money and now
they're still it's just 105 billion a
month so
i think that's their problem and so if
they're going to break back and not buy
that paper and let's face it
they've supported this whole machine
here oh gosh you know everything and
so i everybody asked me so what do you
think about the future and i said well
the only thing i can tell you is we
won't know
until two things happen
and you've talked about this
the supply chain gets straightened out
and number two
they take all the buying away
in the market they're talking about you
know
and i don't i i think the supply chain
will get straightened out i don't know
about the latter
you probably know more than anybody on
that well that gets us to really i mean
and you've spoken about this is is the
role that that fiscal policy
has played
after the i call it the flash recession
of march and april of 2020 right uh
and
but you've you've you mentioned a very
interesting distortion
that's been introduced in the
supplemental nutrition
assistance program snap what we used to
call food stamps
uh
walk me through this one more time
because this is well amazing and again i
think it was the day that
the day that there was something
something bad happened in the world that
biden immediately announced
right that he was going to be increasing
this program and a lot
a lot and i can't take credit for this
you know most of my knowledge i get from
somebody else and i don't mind saying
that by the way
but i had a person in the industry said
hey let me let me just tell you what's
going on here and then i started
noticing it
because food inflation was really going
up yeah and this person said uh well let
me just tell you here's what happens i
am a very very poor person that gets a
card and let's say it's built up over
time they drop cash into it everybody
has a card they don't have you don't
have the stamps anymore right and let's
say they've
hit me with eight or ten thousand
and maybe my brother has eight or ten
thousand too so
we sort of cut a deal and i go sell my
card to somebody for 50 cents on the
dollar
and now i take that money and so i can
do anything by jewelry i can buy booze
cigarettes whatever sure okay but i
can't buy food i'm not buying food
anymore right so see
nobody in this those kinds of systems
knows what's going on and you wonder why
food prices
keep on going up well
if if i never had any money in my life
and i only my biggest year was fifteen
thousand dollars of gross income right
and somebody says hey by the way now
you can buy we're gonna do you can buy
everything now you buy lobster
you name it we'll buy beef tenders
anything you want okay filet mignon
every night why not
well of course why not and that's what
that's just one one area if you took
25 other areas the same thing nobody
nobody knows what's going on and that's
all so i'm going to ask you a question
that's going to sound political but it's
not
and that how important is joe manchin
to the united states of america
i think he's the most important person
right now and
we've always in the business uh we we
still we just we look at things and we
don't try to draw a political line on it
and you know like come down hardcore one
way or the other of course we're just
looking at the facts okay and the facts
are this
if you don't have somebody like that and
i've listened to in the last couple of
days if you know somebody like that that
has at least some voice of reason
you're going to go off the deep end in a
hurry
you know i mean all he's saying is let's
just stop and study right what some of
this stimulus
what some of these unintended
consequences
have been that's all he's saying is
let's let's hit the pause button and go
look back and see what
injecting
three 42.3 of gdp
into directly deposited accounts what
all that cash did
well i think average person too doesn't
understand the physical policy monetary
policy every person on the street
but in the
old days you know banks created the
money right because you went through the
bank bank loan the money and it did
something to the economy
but when you start taking the government
in washington and they start firing all
this money direct they go around the
banks okay and that's why you see loan
to man and i'm part of a bank and i'm in
a great bank but it but
you'll see that go lower okay because
and the reason is because
they're taking they're pushing the money
straight to these people yep
and that's why and and your friend and
my friend lacy hunt yep that's that's
what he's always said hey if
if i ever change stripes
it's because they keep firing that money
out there and they go around everybody
and they're they've done some of that
well yeah i mean people don't like to
hear it but i like to say it i mean
we've taken universal basic income on a
test drive and it failed yeah it did and
and it
you know you
the old idea that if something for
nothing you know
it's never worked
i mean in the long run if it doesn't
work i mean it may work for short term
but it doesn't work and that's that's
what's happened
so um
education in america
obviously
your undergraduate
degree while you work 40 hours a week
kind of set you on a path
what about the least what about the
children who've been left behind
i mean what
what are your views on on how to fix
education so that all children no matter
how
what station they're born into can
actually get an education in america
well as you know i'm i'm a big big
advocate of foster children so talk to
me about these two foundations because
i'm fascinated fascinated fascinated
well i you know i read a book about 26
or seven years ago i uh called a boy
called that out of california and he was
a foster child you know abused and it
was really it was really touching to me
and i just decided i said you know what
i think i'm going to do is whatever i
spend at the country club every month
i'm going to give to foster kids too so
i just started doing it without a
foundation and got some i was having to
put out so much money
and so
i started was going to a private
foundation and the lawyer said well you
know take a year and a half they don't
really trust you whatever i said well i
want to do it anyway and they
sent it to dallas
this lady called me and said hey
this is five days later she said
tell you what if you'll make this a
public foundation of 501c3 you can get a
lot more money for these kids she had to
be a foster child
i said you know because bureaucracy
doesn't work in five days i said i'll do
that
she turned around two weeks yeah
and so
that's how it all got cranking and what
happened where was where was the first
one located first one south of san
antonio we have 30 something counties
my mother was born and raised she was
born in moore and raised in pearsall
okay well we can go here's all high we
go to pierce all the way down to the
valley and up to victoria but south of
victoria but
um
but my my problem with it all was a lot
of kids foster kids are under the radar
so you don't get a chance
to see what they're doing you know
because they're awards of the state i
can't go mentor one every weekend
so we developed a foundation that did
two things one we wanted to get things
for them that built their self-esteem
and two we wanted a very quick
turnaround
so we get a request from a case worker
for a child
48 hours
no matter what it is okay
so
what happens is
if you go to these county welfare boards
and things like that the government
agencies
if i wanted a pair of jeans for a kid
five months
you know four months i mean everybody's
talking about let's do this
they've got money but they don't have to
do anything with it so we jumped it and
we went straight to you know child
protective services and said we can help
you
and we have a great relationship with
them by the way and
so and then we it was so effective those
are god's workers yeah oh and they don't
make any money that's why i'm saying
yeah yeah it's incredible
so then we decided to do 31 other
counties which is around austin
and it's the same way
it's effective
but but it's
you know the gift is my i mean i i
receive more than probably ever see just
in seeing them something happen of
course but i get a really good feel for
what you're talking about on this
educational thing because
um
i think the problem the biggest problem
today is we
it starts with administrative
educational administrations in education
and
i really believe if you had a simple
system where you could go to the
teachers of the world and say i'll tell
you what
we're going to cut out all this money
and all these regulations at the top and
we're going to pay you to teach okay and
we're going to pay a little more money
to teach by the way
and we're also going to hire more of you
so we can get these situations where if
i bring a kid in this classroom
they learn something right okay and and
we're not
you're not just a referee yeah and we're
going to try to teach them the skills
to you know to move forward and at the
same time i don't think every child is
meant to go to college i really don't i
think there's a an end to that but you
could help them in that way too you
could say i'll tell you what
uh
through these other courses through
junior high high school we're also going
to start teaching you if we feel like
you want to go toward a vocational side
sure then we're going to help you with
that too i think you have to jump the
system though because
it's just like the foster care system
there's so much stuff at the top that
you can't get down to the kids
that's one of the problems and but in
education is really it's steeped in that
wow and so the unions are powerful yeah
but i i and i think if you really opened
up charter schools to say to
particularly under privileged people
families tell you what
what we'll do we're going to allow you
go to any of these schools out here
we'll give you transportation to get
over there but we want your kids
to really be something
that's where you start and right now
i don't know if you saw this but about
10 days ago there's an op-ed in the wall
street and the guy was from china and he
was here working on phd and maybe it was
columbia but somewhere up there
and he said you know what my kids are in
the third grade here and so they went
the first two or three grades in china
he went through all of what they had to
do
he said down here in the fourth grade or
whatever it was i still have it i can
send it to you but he said
you know what we do every day they want
to know what kind of healthy snack
they're bringing to school
and he said on the third by the third
day
zero
zero homework
he said
i don't know what to tell you here he
says
how am i going to educate this kid and
so you know he's from china
and so i'm thinking to myself
that's the problem
with us in china
well i'll tell you my
my twins are in in chinese right now and
every day they say why do we have
homework every day and i'm like because
it's chinese that's right
it's a different type of
mindset
but since you raised the subject
do
where do you think the dollar is
one day
well i think right now
you know it's been stronger recently
it's been so i think right now oh i mean
it's ultimate fate okay i'm talking
about i'm talking about whether there
are any parallel because we've got a
little bit of an income inequality
problem in this game sure uh i think the
the ultimate fate will be like the 40s
into the 50 where
you won't realize it
but that buying power just goes away in
a way in a way by the time you get to
the end of it you're like you know what
i still have the same amount of money
but
i can't i can't buy anything or
something like that and so
i think that's ultimately where we're
headed
i have to say this and you know i i
i do i've been blessed myself to
to have monetary wealth
and so i'm a very very blessed thankful
person but i will tell you what i
think's happened i think in many many
ways and i think it's really started on
wall street
that the what the big wealth
has forgotten about
how the game really should go which is
you want everybody to move up okay you
want that middle class
to stay middle class you want those
people to have to have upward mobility i
mean that's that's the american dream
really we don't have that now
and and i watched all the phases i
watched it when we when i came to
business only one owner family
and you had started inflating then all
of a sudden you had 200 families and
then i saw we went into credit card
credit cards then we went into the
yuppies
and we ended the home debt and then we
refinanced four times
you know
this kept going i mean we kept going
until you're where you are today which
is these people that don't make any
money
people you know we have this whole one
percent up here
they don't i'm not certain they even
have a clue i don't think i'm not
certain they uh
in west palm and just
driving around i'm just like yeah do
they know how blatant they're being with
their wealth yeah and i i want i'm a i'm
a capitalist and i'll tell you wait big
time
but i'm also a realist and if you see
these countries that
in the end don't do well
kind of like rome yeah or great britain
they end up
like a lot of south american countries a
little bit up here and a lot down here
and in the end if you look at it though
this is my point it gets to the currency
in the end in the end
in the end you might think it's okay now
just because you know we're the big
we're the big cheese around but we might
not be ten years from now and that's
usually what happens that's what i think
will happen into the dollar
interesting um
so
if if your clients are asking you right
now for guidance
what are you telling them
well are there are there any places to
hide
well i think the way you're where your
height is balance
okay that's where you think you hide now
i'll just give you an idea we're we're
simpletons i will say so i'm i'm not
like
uh
uh and i take his stuff too i'm i'm i'm
not like keith uh at hedgehog that
i mean you know our people couldn't do
that even though i think a lot of it by
the way and i think it's i think there's
so many different ways
uh you know chris here there's a lot of
ways where people do really well in the
business but you have to
you have to align that with the way
people feel or or they can understand
well for us we're
we're pretty simpletons because a lot of
our people had a business they're simple
and they think you know i know how this
works so we have like three strategies
we have a really conservative strategies
never lost money we have a we have a
strategy in the middle called high
income that
is designed to beat the bond market
which it always does but it doesn't own
any bonds
interesting enough
it's all cash flow though and then we
have a stock strategy but in
what we do with people that have and
because i tell people today that sell a
company oh by the way
man you picked the greatest time in the
world to sell your company
however
you picked the worst time to start
investing
so that's a two things
and they always say uh yeah but i got to
do something then i ask this question so
let me ask you did you get 50 or 100
more for your company than you really
thought it was worth yeah i did so i
said well then what's wrong
with just kind of hanging loose for two
or three or four years sure you got
twice as much you thought you get anyway
right so why go out and have to burn it
up so what my advice though to people is
the reason you have to have balance is
this
if we don't know what the future holds
and we don't know okay
then
we're going to be in a situation where
our middle strategy produces cash flow
and you need that to live on
and we want a cash flow stream
that's coming no matter what we have so
many things in there we have
convertibles and reits and pipelines and
energy and metals and we have
uh fertilizer all sorts of things but
everything pays a cash flow stream sure
and um
that's what you have to have today well
you can't fudge cash flows and you can't
fudge revenues there's two things that
you can't do and i know people look at
that and say well
you know since 1992 that's been sort of
a
six you know five and three quarter six
percenter on average and i said yeah it
is but
you got to have it okay that beats zero
it it's what you're gonna go get you
know parking it in a bank yeah and we've
always had a really in our conservative
portfolios we've always uh
and that part comes from me being in
around the 70s and early 80s but we've
always kept everything within about 60
months
and we had about 15 20 that we really
had long paper in but we didn't buy any
after
19 or so
so a lot of that's going to is running
off and then we have a stock
portfolio that is
not it's not
exchange-rated funds or indexes or
companies and we try to buy companies
that can
we think can make
15 or so over the next five years
annually and and
and we use a
we look we discount it and try to buy
the discounted number if we can okay
fundamental analysis exactly
you know how it is then my gosh yeah i
know folio management 101 what an
antiquated thought well and to be able
and i know you can appreciate this but
so many people today if i mean in the
business
can't read a balance sheet in an income
statement
and that's why that's why financial
advisor as you said earlier as an option
well
i will tell you most commercial bankers
can read a balance sheet an income
statement
better than i bet half of the investment
community
everywhere
because all they they what they do is
they buy
okay
i'm going to buy the
art fund okay
they don't know what's in it they don't
know what the companies do they have no
idea if they're making any money
but it looks good to me okay and
they don't do that now so what we do is
we own
things we don't but and i'll tell you
where it comes in handy when times go
bad
if you only own these all these
one-liners and people walk in what are
you gonna tell them
well
yeah they're all down but if i can show
somebody hey let me tell you what you
own here okay this company
that we really love okay
and we bought it at this level but now
we can buy it
25 cheaper we're going to buy some more
of it yeah okay
it's got a strong balance it's got free
cash flow and it's got true revenues and
all you know all those all those things
i'll tell you about for example on the
high income account and and you can
remember this well
uh march of 09
in that first quarter we found things
that were yielding in the in the high
income
they were yielding 14 16 18 points what
a nice what a nice thought and we had
liquidity so
we put it in imagine those that that's
why that was those that was one of the
three best years we ever had
because we had liquidity
and you could you know but what i'm
saying is you could i could go to
somebody and say now look okay i'm going
to show you this business okay right
here
this is how much debt they have this is
how much cash flow they have and i know
it's getting hammered in the market but
i want you to look at the value on it
okay
and then i start comparing it to a piece
of income producing real estate because
they can understand real estate
the average person
can understand real estate they can say
so that's a eight or nine percent cash
on cash on that piece of property and
yeah okay
well i we we get in that mode with them
and so all of a sudden they're like
all right i'm good and the other side of
it is we always have this piece over
here that's what i call the buffer yeah
the cushion
so that you have to in bad bad times you
have to go back and say
now's the time
so um there's one area that has exploded
i keep using that word exploded but and
that's private equity oh yeah
what effect has private equity had on
price discovery because it's its own
beast i mean i don't think private
equity would be as big as it is today if
it wasn't for central bank policy
right
yes
yeah
well i think
you know well i'll tell you this and i'm
not telling you anything because you
know all this
but wall street
is the genius
at dreaming up anything that works okay
and they can sell all right and i watch
them through all of these things okay
you know they they they had the big 50
that when i first came in the business
then if you remember they went into
limited partnerships they limited
partner everything real estate that was
for you know rtc
and then they came along and we dropped
uh the you know commissions
and so you left
the stockbrokers in the loot you know
they're out in the coal now so we're
going to come in and we're going to
start
you know doing it for a fee and we're
going to put it over here with this
person then
that got too proliferated and then so
they said well
let's go start buying real estate
private businesses uh
everything we can think of and we're
going to do it in
private equity
okay and here's where we're going
everybody's got to have it we're going
to charge you an annual fee we're going
to charge you a fee when we go buy that
whatever it is we're going to charge you
a fee to take care of it we're going to
charge you a fee when we sell it and
then we're going to split with you
after the profit okay then we're going
to we're going to show you
so that's how that all came along and so
what happened is
i can't tell you how many
people women and men that i met that are
say 40
or 45 what are you doing
well so and so we started a private
event
and we yeah how long you've been doing
about five years how's it going oh
we are killing them
always i have a second question though
danielle have you sold anything yet
uh-huh
no because we have a we have a seven to
eight nine year
time frame we're looking at i think
yeah but i said if you look
so if you looked at the numbers if you
have to get liquid here okay about you
know
but you can walk through that thing and
so when i go to investors and everything
that have talking hey i'm looking at
this private equity though and i'd say
okay one big mistake you make if you buy
a private company is
you need to know
the people that owned it
like if you invest if we invest in a
private company
which i do and some other people do it's
not that we offer it to our investors
very much but you know what we key on
the people sure like a community banker
and making it alone in the olden days
you know what they knew they knew the
people they knew
you'd make a great fit head
because you know the deal
you know though you know all the stuff
see we don't have anybody like that but
we but what happens is
that that to me is what's going to
prompt the private equity they bid up
everything they bid up and you the piece
you wrote yesterday was fabulous about
how much powder was out there to go in
to buy real estate just for commercial
real estate just that one thing just
that one area but we see it though in
private businesses
they'll come along and a company that we
think should sell for say six times
pre-tax
they're paying 14 times
so
they'll come around and and and they'll
say you know and i have a question for
them always and is so what what's the
end game here like what do you
where are you going what are you what
are you going to how are you going to
turn that so i'm paying 14 or 15 times
pre-tax i'll tell you and by the way
two years from now the owner who really
is the brains
is gone oh yeah so and see they deal
okay during these kinds of periods
because money's loosed all that kind of
thing sure but when you finally get
to the end and that's probably maybe
five six seven eight years from now and
everybody has to sell to liquidate
then we're going to find out
and that's the problem
well okay so in the next five to seven
years can we go back and end with why
you think ut football's going to get
better
please
well i think for a long time yeah i
think um
and i have to do this for my wife
because she's at ut
i was going to say you're you're texting
me i'm not i didn't go to ut but i have
to do that for her do you root for
i do i root for texas too but i mean i
root for my alma mater too but um
you know what wait wait what do you say
get your guns up no i don't do that very
much i just say yeah they don't very
they don't win much in the way of
football i love them don't get me wrong
but i want them to but
and i i the thing about it is is that
i sort of have to do that i'm married so
i have to do that but
uh they have a great coach and i think
people realize he's got a really great
offspring in his mind but if you look i
could give you this information
but if you look this is really this is
the most important subject that we've
covered today so i really want to know
the last three years of classes that
they recruited which was
basically
i'm say four years 18 19 20 and 21. if
you could look in there and see
how many players they lost they either
went that left went to pro went to
another team
he's operating with not even 50 percent
of what he should have right and so he's
like they don't have an offensive or
defensive line
we got a coaching position for you
so even i can tell they don't have a
either line so uh so if you give him
time he's a smart guy
and i really think one of the things i
like about him is that
i i love people that have overcome
and yes like you and like and all the
other people you know out there and he's
he's done that and i like that about him
and so that just means that he'll have
the ability to really think a little
bigger than i need to win the next game
i want to look at a big picture
we'll see but i you know
i i think you'll do well so
one last other last question is should
ou and ut have joined the sec
well this is a really important matter
out of my pay grade but i think so and
from this respect they we're getting
you know this whole game is becoming uh
a big business oh it's it's getting
games yeah the game is getting you look
at the balance they paid these coaches
just this year in these these last five
or six that went up
so i think they did in this respect uh
that the smaller schools
are going to keep on losing revenue and
the bigger schools can keep on gaining
it and
um
i i know it probably feels uh like
they've been slighted you know the other
schools but i don't think they had a lot
of choice because
they
if they're going to really recruit they
kind of get in a big
a big area either big 10
or southeastern conference not so much a
pac-12 but i think
i think the pac-12 will come around
eventually too they've been they've been
good in the past but
well i will say this much so this is my
theory yeah if
if you're a boy in texas now and you're
some freshman or sophomore i actually
know an eighth grader who's who was
offered something mississippi state or
somewhere eighth grader well they're
getting very aggressive but if if you
have the choice of going to texas
i mean immediately playing because we
don't have enough players or going to ou
or going to a m or going to some place
where you're going to sit on the bench
right see that that's what i think the
secret sauce is i think we're going to
be able to get boys who want to play
football well you took you took the
words out of my mouth if i'm a really
good defensive lineman or offensive
lineman and
i'm i'm not speaking for the coach but
i'm sure he's saying something like that
like hey you know what you wouldn't have
to be here until you're a junior
how about the second game sure
this is good this is great okay okay
you've made my day
when i come back in a year we're gonna
have a winning season right if we if we
sit down again i bet i bet texas does in
a year yeah okay well i'm i'm gonna hold
you to that yeah i'll tell you what
i'll buy you dinner if they don't you
buy me dinner if they do
oh okay well that all right that works
okay oh i i just think you reversed it
though i reversed it you should be
buying me i should be buying you dinner
if they don't you buy me another they
don't okay and i'll buy you dinner if
they do
well some good barbecue you're a great
uh
you're really a great ambassador for
the university of texas in going to
school and all of that i know people
know who you are
well i'm happy to be back here in austin
i'm happy to have spoken with you i'm
happy to put you on the spot for once um
but i look forward to the next time that
you're interviewing me as well but but
thank you for spending so much time this
afternoon i really appreciate it i do
appreciate it i have to tell you
i've never told anybody the things i
told you today
but it's okay i'm all right with it but
i i it's interesting i've never talked
about that kind of thing because it's
really never about me it's always about
other people children have to have a
reason to dream that's what i say yeah
they they have to know that they can
come from anywhere and accomplish
something and we've got to get back to
to that in this country and i feel
strongly about well thanks for having me
thank you appreciate it all right it's
fun to hear people's true stories
uh
and
ted ted gave us his all and i'm so
pleased i hope you enjoyed it as well uh
i i will say i got the same level of
depth out of somebody else you might be
interested in and that's grant williams
who's also always the one doing the
interviewing so if you happen to miss
that episode of down the middle go back
and watch it and you'll appreciate who
grant is as well as you now appreciate
who ted is so until next time this is
danielle dimartino booth with down the
middle thank you
[Music]